hey it's Andy couch here and that's how
you choose a video we're actually not
gonna look at this uh this week's tidy
Tuesday data set I believe it's on
caribou Calver instead I was actually
reading your guys's comments and one of
you asked me to make a video on how to
make many models or essentially nested
models and I thought be fun to do this I
opened up the R for data science
textbook and thought we funding to go
through their chapter on many models
specifically on how to make many linear
models to explain some trends and in
this data set I also thought it'd be
kind of fun to go and apply the tidy
models to the many models um tutorial
and we're actually gonna use the same
data set which is Gapminder additionally
um you may notice that this video book
looks a little bit different however I
just wanted to basically film this on my
laptop just to make sure I could do this
wall is traveling in case I I wasn't by
a desktop so we're gonna just use my
laptop for this tire Tuesday but it
should all be the same so we're going to
look up the tidy Tuesday tight Tuesday
and then I'm gonna make this a little
bit bigger we'll zoom in a little bit
okay
Oh actually just I only had not used a
shiny documents I want to load up a
markdown from templates kept document
there you go okay so write that
okay so we're gonna do it all this
garbage name this tidy Tuesday many
models and then load in what's here tidy
vers tidy models the broom package which
I think comes with tidy models and also
Gapminder ok so I think we got most of
that stuff what's here
you didn't run everything ok cool
so Gapminder is basically like a bunch
of countries we can kind of look at some
summary statistics by just doing some
counts so let's count first country
continents and that's basically it this
is a pretty narrow data set where
there's only about six columns that we
really need to look at to get minder
count country we can see that there's a
hundred and forty two countries maybe
count continents we can see that there's
five continents and included in this
data set or most of the countries or
most of the data comes from Africa cool
so well we're actually gonna do with
from the R for data science was it
package our textbook we're gonna look at
Gapminder and that's basically and
instead of doing some predictive
modeling we're actually gonna try to
analyze residuals so one way to use
models is basically figure out what
can't be explained with the given
features so in this case they use they
use just linear models to basically
explains this linear trend and then they
have the remaining pattern which is the
residuals with years so that's the stuff
that they can't really explain way
to give in um you know with a given GDP
per capita and stuff like that so let's
start doing that the baseline thing we
should always do is just let's create a
baseline model so let's do a linear
model predicting life expectancy with
the cat minder data right and then we
have a baseline model and we have that
stuff additionally what we should
actually do what we can do is we can use
the broom package and do a tidy function
on it in this case we can look at all
the coefficients the p-values in a clean
fashion we'd also use the the glance to
look at summary statistics of this model
so r-squared adjusted r-squared
AIC bi see scores stuff like that and
finally which is probably the most
useful is we can use the augment
function which will basically use our
baseline model and put and predict upon
our data set that would train it on and
we can actually look at the residuals
which is right here so if we use the
augment and we do ggplot a yes x equals
here y equals dot rigid rigid and then
we could do like a genome I don't know
point and just kind of look at the chart
all right so we can see there's you know
a decent amount of data that cannot be
explained with our given model okay cool
so what we should be really looking at
now is when can we apply nested models
or many models and the idea of the
nested models are many models is we
basically use a we pair it with two main
functions a group by and then so we can
do a group by and then a nest
so we already basically know what group
by so we're gonna just say you know
we're gonna make groups of whatever
factor or whatever categorical variable
but the nest will basically consolidate
whatever group by function into a data
set
so if we actually use the nest function
without using group I it just makes a
listed table and this table is our
actual Gapminder data sum we end up so
when we apply the group by and then the
nest we basically have little subsets of
data for each continent and that can be
pretty useful or trying to make many
models so we when we do this we also
have to decide what do we want to group
by we could group by continent which is
about five org you'd group by country
which if we look at here minder count
country we see that there's a hundred
forty two countries so we kind of cool
make let's make a hundred forty two
models and do that but I personally
don't think it's a good idea to make too
many models one thing that one reason
why I was a little hesitant to make this
video is I really don't subscribe to
fact that a lot of times many models
will help you in this circumstance many
models is basically used not as a
prediction problem but more as a
analytics problem we're trying to figure
out okay what can't be explained by a
model which can be useful however since
we're gonna also incorporate idea models
I think it's important to realize that a
bunch of nested models are much upon
holes fitted for each factor can result
into overfitting so with that being said
I think what we should do is actually
group by continent
and make many models for each content or
make a model for each client which would
which it would result in to five models
okay so first we have our baseline model
and now we're gonna plot create a
baseline model for each continent so how
can we do that well we already have our
data and basically what we want to do is
we want to create a baseline multiple
times and we could just do it where we
could do a loop or we could do some
filters and just do this process over
and over again but luckily the tidy
verse has a map function so we can do a
mutate and we can say we can create a
model and we can do math and we give it
and the map Falcon has a accent
which ways has an input in a function in
this case our input will be data and now
we have to figure out a function and
there's two ways to do it we could just
do a def word we could just make a
function oops hmm do that could do a
function and just say LM life expectancy
data equals X right and that base says
we're gonna create use this function and
apply it for each data and create one
little model right that's pretty
straightforward additionally what we
could do is we could just create a
helper function say create based online
model and we'll give it a X and well
let's just say LM life expectancy data
equals x so these are the same thing but
in my opinion it'll look a little bit
cleaner so if we do this and we just
kind of do eat all this garbage and you
say create baseline model it'll do the
same thing so what I would recommend is
saying this probably is the better this
way is a better way it's been poor to
make um functions readable it's
important to make your code readable and
to name your functions to what they do
what they're actually doing you don't
need to make it um super technical you
just want to say well we just want to
create a baseline model and then they
can look at the create baseline model
function and they can say oh you know
you sees the linear model function and
you're trying to produce predictor life
expectancy with with whatever data you
throw at it so we're gonna do that so
now we have our models we can also do
another function where we can say map
we're going to mutate and say results
equals map model and then augment I
think see if that works
okay now we have our results from the
model so if we were basically doing is
we're gonna predict we're gonna give it
the we're gonna use our models or are
many models and then predict upon the
data that it was trained upon and we can
also we can actually look at the
residuals so we're gonna do that
we're gonna select select continent and
results and to and once we have that we
still see that these things are still
listed tables luckily there's a simple
function called on nest so now we have
on all of these datasets that are just
unnecessary or kind of like spread out
I'm just gonna do a ungroup and then
we're going to select continent year and
d'autres it alright and then we can do a
simple Gigi pot yes x equals year y
equals doctors in plus Jim would you
plank plus facet wrap by continent
scales equals free y now was well these
skills equals fix from now I'm what else
we want to do we probably wanna throw in
a color so color equals continent okay
let's see what that looks like okay and
now we can see something for one thing
we could actually do a alpha equals
point one maybe do a Geum smooth
okay so we can see how our models
definitely are a little bit different
well good also actually not even do a
facet wrap what's held it let's see what
that looks like yeah okay I don't I'm
not really a fan of that okay so we can
see how um with Africa it's much there's
there's much more residual noise right
the rituals are more spread out compared
to say Oceania Europe America so if you
look at Americas Europe an ocean ocean
ocean yeah I don't I don't know how to
pronounce that very well I'm sorry if
I'm butchering that but we can see how
basically these three countries are
pretty it's pretty easy to explain
um the life expectancy however with
Africa and Asia there might may be more
factors that we might have to introduce
or maybe more factors that we're missing
you know we're missing more contacts
behind it it's pretty interesting to do
right so yeah so that's a basic so this
is like basic basic many linear models
for each continent but one big thing
between this is okay well how can we do
this but with more complex models like
what if you wanted to do something crazy
where oh let's do a bunch of boosted
models um I personally wouldn't do that
but what we could do with Tidy models is
we get it start adding interaction
effects for each each country or each
continent and one good model that we
could use is a Mars model or the multi
variable variate adapter regression
splines and they can basically find
these interactions for you when I was my
previous video on interactions with
mostly Jada linear model interactions
using the recipes package but I figured
let's just do let's just create mini
Mars models and see what that does okay
so we're gonna do that okay so first
what we have to do is
kind of think about how we're gonna
approaches well with with uh with Mars
models with any tidy models what we're
gonna need to do is basically create a
recipe for always models because there's
a bunch of dummy variables okay
so let's first do that so we'll just say
okay we'll make a Mars recipe and the
recipe will involve life expectancy and
the data will equal to in this case
since we've been saying X we'll say X
and just then test out these rest these
functions will just assign X to the cat
minder data set actually no I got when
we think about something actually we'll
just do Gapminder what's a filter
continent equals let's say what's say
America's there we go so and then we'll
say select - continent since I'm
thinking we'll just do it the this the
continent level models will just create
a single um model for the single
continent if that makes sense
so we're gonna do that and we're going
to assign it to X just so we can kind of
test our code as we go along okay so we
have a Mars recipe our data equals x and
we're just gonna say we'll step a little
step normal will use the step normalized
and we'll say all numeric - all was it
outcomes and step dummy and it was a all
nominal
so if we look at our Mars recipe oops
and we prep the recipe just see what it
does and we can say that it did
centering and scaling four year
population GDP per capita and they
create dummy variables for the country
and that's what we want okay
additionally what we could do which is a
little bit more advanced is how are we
gonna tune the model and how we're gonna
clean the model for each continent maybe
each comment will require different
tuning parameters right and that's well
then where it's something where machine
learning really becomes an art where you
cut or you kind of have to decide and
make these arbitrary decisions on how it
fits with the data or if you're a
researcher you probably know more than I
would so you could either do more of
just kind of a test it and and see the
results or you could read a bunch of
academic journals and figure that out
but in this case we're gonna do it
because it's probably the most easiest
way to do it especially if you don't
have a lot of domain knowledge is just
do some classic carrot k-fold
cross-validation tuning so that's we're
gonna do I want to say Mars K oops K
folds Oh actually it's here try and
decide if I want to you know we don't
need to do it so Mars K folds and it was
a v-fold CV X cool and then yeah so one
thing what does thing about maybe I
should split in the training test sets
however since we're not really using it
as a particular modeling problem we're
really just using this to do interaction
effect modeling and specifically if
you're using interpret all models to
figure out and analyze the coefficients
we really don't need to worry about data
leakage we're just using the the K folds
to essentially find the correct
parameters that we want to use it for
okay so what else we need to do is make
a Mars model so we'll say Mars model and
we just say
right Mars yeah and then what we want to
tune is the number of terms in this case
we're gonna let it decide and we'll say
product prod to green and we'll let that
tune set mode to regression and then set
engine to Earth and I'm pretty sure
earth is the only engine you can use
from marshmallows boma not sure okay
finally now we actually have to make a
grid for our K folds of 200 on so we'll
say Mars grid grid regular and then
we'll give it the parameters for any
Mars model and our levels will be ten
cool if we look at our Mars grid oops
Mars grid we can see that okay it's
pointing like this is how many terms you
want just the degree Yatta Yatta okay so
now let's create a workflow so Mars
workflow workflow ad model Mars mano and
recipe Mars recipe and boom and then
finally what we're gonna do is we're
gonna start creating our results for
marching grid so Mars res Mars workflow
tune grid our resamples will be the Mars
K folds our grid will be the Mars grid
and our metrics in this case I think our
metrics should be a ma yi I think that's
the best mean absolute error addition we
could do our MSE but I think I think
mean absolute error is the easiest thing
to interpret it and it can kind of suit
as residuals if you really wanted to
kind of look at it so and then we're
gonna do that and run the model so I'm
gonna pause it and we'll come back to
see if it actually worked
okay so the Mars models fixed uh came
out and we can kind of do the collect
metrics thing however we already know
the best way to do it so we'll say Mars
res select best and we'll say ma we can
look at our Mars tune oops Mars tune let
me see five terms with a product degree
of two cool and that's like I think
product degree is basis the way how we
can determine the the order of
interactions so this is a second-order
interaction with five terms great and
then we'll do is finalize our workflow
by doing Mars workflow finalized for
coil and we'll say Mars tune right and
then we'll make our final model by doing
the final model and we'll say fit Mars
workflow with our X which is our cat
minor data and I'll basically do they'll
create a final model using the entire
data with the given parameters that we
used a k-fold cross-validation on and it
also saved the recipe model and yadda
yadda so we'll have create a final model
that we can actually use in our final
many models function so I'm gonna do
that and we have for that so final hanno
cool I think we also use like predict
final mono an x-ray and I'll give our
predictions right here great so that's
all said and done we kind of have our
entire thing that we want to do so this
is saying that for each if you actually
look what we're trying to do so I'm
going to bring this in or say create
Mars model function function function so
basically
for this for each data each continents
data we're gonna basically create split
the data into ten folds and our in five
folds I think five folds tuned a model
with a get with ten different parameters
figure out the best parameters using
each fold given the bet by using that
best ma e and then we're gonna train the
final model using the parameters on the
contents contents data so it's gonna
reproduce this entire this entire
process five times okay so that's we're
gonna do another thing that we should
also add is the cat function and we'll
say model completed and I'll just print
off model completed and I mean I think
it's - n so if I if I do that those two
Mach would so we'll do that so what were
we gonna do we're gonna basically create
a Mars function so we'll say create Mars
model function X boom okay and then
we'll return the final model
okay and I'm actually gonna make sure to
delete what is it oops
I'm gonna do it all this stuff just to
make sure I don't have any leakage so
I'm gonna rerun that actually I'll just
I'll just do this this little thing I'll
just run all chunks below should be
pretty fast I'm not too worried about it
okay and now we'll say train nested Mars
models okay so we'll do the Gapminder
group by continent oops goodbye
continent nest it
and then finally create our model which
is our create Mars model oh and we have
to use the map function and say data and
create Mars model boom and it will say
many Mars will say uh will say Mars
model what do we call it Mars models
okay so once we have that we're gonna
run it and once the first create model
created pops up I'm gonna go and pause
it and let it run because it's
essentially you're doing training up
like five models for each continent
tuning it and then fitting another one
so it's like six models are being fitted
times five so I just thought 30 miles
are being created which is pretty fun so
let's see it do it just trying to wait
what else can we do okay so this is
taking a little bit longer so I'm just
gonna pause it and I will come back when
it finishes recording we're finishes
modeling okay so you can see how the
model completed showed up five times
which means all of our models were
successfully trained yeah that's hard to
say and we see continent data model what
we could also want to do is since we
have our models we're gonna actually
analyze our residuals and then plot out
per year so that's what we're gonna do
we're gonna do a we're going to use a
mutate and we'll say results equals map
to because we're gonna use two inputs in
this case it'll be our model our data
and what the int and the function will
be predict so you can't I don't think
you can when you're using map to or P
map which has more than two inputs it's
kind of important to figure out kind of
like I guess the
the logical order of it so if you do
data and model I think I'll run into
errors yep so it's it's probably
important to be a little wary of that
but you know you you can switch it
around and you'll have you'll be fine
now we're gonna do is select continent
continent data and results and we'll do
a on nest all right so now we have our
prediction for a life expectancy and
then our year thing cool and then we'll
do a ungroup igg plot a yes
x equals year y equals o actually it
just said we also have to do is mute add
to create residual so mutate Raziel
equals um life expectancy - dot pred
right actually I think I'm pretty sure
that's how however zeros are calculated
when we check it out
residual fitted where's the yep yeah he
is it's twenty eight point eight minus
twenty eight point eight minus twenty
eight point three so it should be eight
point four okay that's that's right so I
was right
okay so meaty eight residuals and then
we'll finally do a GG plot so GG y is x
equals year y equals was it rigid color
equals continent plus Jim point alpha
equals point 1 plus facet wrap by a
continent scales equals fixed and we'll
do a was it a genome smooth s equals
what's and then we'll say uh yeah genome
smooth and throw that in there and we
can see that we can see that it doubles
the same story
however we actually have accounted more
for Oceania and I think for Europe let
me actually bring it back down you bring
this one yeah we'll just bring that down
to just something for some care of
Harrisons okay so you can see that they
basically did the same thing but the but
we get a little bit different results
and we kind of learned more on how to
make multi-level models I know this is a
pretty quick video but I think it was
kind of fun to do some more tidy model
stuff and if you guys want to do if you
guys have any more suggestions for what
I want what you guys want to see for
next week just comment and I'm sure I'll
make a video on it so yeah anyways I see
you guys next week in Teddy on